hallo leute ich es wieder eure mal
wander und willkommen zu einem neuen
video und ich glaube das ist das
positivste video auf meinem ganzen kanal
denn ich kann euch etwas ganz schönes
verkünden meine panikattacken sind weg
und sie sind nicht einfach so über nacht
verschwunden und ich bin morgens
aufgestanden und dachte mir oh das leben
ist wieder schön
nein ich habe viele dinge dafür getan
sechs monate lang gestreichelt und kann
euch heute verraten was meine besten
tipps sind wie man panikattacken wieder
schnell loswerden kann
ich hoffe ich kann alles wirklich gut
zusammen setzen und erzählen und hätte
mir auch sachen aufschreiben können da
hat sich aber das wird anfühlt wie so
eine sache aus dem herzen
kann ich irgendwie nicht so viel mit dem
kopf rein deswegen erzähle ich euch das
einfach aus dem bauch heraus ich werde
jetzt auch hoffentlich ihr kennt mich
ich werde schneiden auch wenn ich sage
ich schneider nicht ob ich hasse jede
redepause deswegen schneiden werde ich
sowieso aber es wird ein lama video es
wird ein etwas längeres lama video ich
hoffe nicht zu lang
es tut mir leid dass ich mit meinem
pollini ganz so ausrastet und meine
größte hoffnung ist mit diesem video
eine weitere person vielleicht aus dem
panikattacken so raus ziehen zu können
denn spoiler mir hat einfach ein youtube
kommentar ich würde es dramatisch mein
leben gerettet nennen
ich würde schon so sagen das ist leben
retten weil wenn man in so panikattacken
drin steckt ist das leben zwar auch
lebenswert
aber es ist halt nicht so schön
als ich in der tief phase war in meinen
panikattacken empfand ich das leben als
sehr sehr anstrengend und nicht als
schöne experience auf diesem tollen
planeten der sich eher den end- und ich
liebe jeden tag es war wirklich das
gegenteil ich habe jeden tag ist radelt
und dachte mir so ich will wieder
durchatmen können ich will irgendwie
wieder rausgehen können ich will
ja alles wieder machen können und nichts
gingen und dann denkst du die ganze zeit
nur daran was nicht geht und es ist
nicht schön
und jeder der da draußen panikattacken
hat ich weiß was ihr durch machen müsst
und ich hoffe wirklich von ganzem herzen
es ist dieses video ich ein bisschen
helfen kann und wenn ich dieses video
das ihr aber irgendwann daraus kommt
wirklich viele vor ihr haben es
geschafft du bist aus schaffen falls ihr
wissen wollt wie meine panikattacken
aufgetaucht sind wann es passiert dass
pipapo dazu habe ich schon video gemacht
ich verlinke euch das unten in der video
beschreibung und für die das schon
gesehen haben und über die situation
schon bescheid wissen wünschte jetzt
viel spaß beim zuhören als meine
panikattacken losging kam sie relativ
häufig also täglich bis dreimal täglich
und manchmal hatte ich richtig starke
panikattacken dass ich was nehmen musste
also ein beruhigungsmittel und manchmal
waren es nur so kurze anflüge die wieder
abgeschafft sind die meisten träger
waren wenn ich ein komisches kribbeln in
den fingern hatte wenn ich irgendwas
ganz besonders toll gespürt habe weil
meine ganze aufmerksamkeit bei eh schon
so in meinem körper drin weil sie
natürlich auch alles gespürt hab was in
mir drin passiert ist das heißt jedes
jeder aussetzer von meinem herzen jeder
jeder kribbeln turin alles alles hat man
mitbekommen und wenn du so auf dein
inneres hörst dass du alles mit bekommst
dann entwickelt dein körper auch
schmerzen oder symptome die gar nicht
richtig da sind beziehungsweise sind sie
dann doch da und man spürt richtig und
das herz tut weh oder man hat dann
wirklich einen tauben arm oder so weil
der kopf sich der halter ein steigert
und ich wollte dass eine ganze zeit
nicht akzeptieren ich dachte ich habe
eine krankheit irgendwas ist mit mir ich
habe irgendein stechen in der brust das
kommt nicht aus meinem kopf sondern es
kommt aus meinem körper
ich muss jetzt erkennen wo die
panikattacken jetzt wieder weg sind
nein das war alles mein kopf
vieles vielleicht nicht also und man
darf ja auch mein stechen in der brust
an
das kann aber einfach aus der
wirbelsäule kommen weil du schreck
gelegen hast oder keine ahnung
man darf die symptome haben man sollte
wirklich zum arzt gehen wenn symptome
beunruhigend werden
aber halt nicht wenn man schon also ja
wenn es alt aus deinem kopf kommt ist es
halt schwer irgendwie das zu akzeptieren
deswegen ist es umso wichtiger dass man
viel mit seinem kopf arbeitet und
aufhört zu ärzten zu rennen weil man
glaubt dass man wirklich was mit dem
körper hat es gibt natürlich immer
ausnahmen und ich will jetzt nicht sagen
wenn du eine körperliche symptome hast
dann gehen nicht zum arzt weil mach es
mache es gerne und lass dir von zwei
ärzten zwei meinungen geben dass alles
in ordnung ist und dann musste aber auch
gut sein lassen wenn es mit diesen
psychischen einher geht nicht wenn du
sonst der glücklichste mensch der welt
bis und eine körperliche so thomas bitte
ich will niemanden jetzt hier von ärzten
fernhalten geht zum arzt los wenn du
irgendwas spürt geht zum arzt setzt euch
dahin nimmt ihr nintendo ds mit und 60
drei stunden warteraum besser als
irgendwie dann ist nicht akzeptieren was
man hat bei mir war es aber so dass es
halt kopf sind also vom kopf ausgelöste
symptome waren und die wand furchtbar
was soll ich sagen die waren echt
scheiße und ich habe als allererstes
habe ich mir einen termin bei einer
hypnose therapeutin geben lassen weil
ich psychotherapie schon kannte und
wusste dass sie helfen würde
ich wollte aber etwas was mich sofort
heilt ich hatte keine lust darauf
monatelang an mir zu arbeiten
bis dieser moment kommt dass ich das
überwunden habe ich wollte dass mir
jemand etwas also etwas mit mir macht
das es wie ein schalter umgelegt wird
und es mir wieder besser geht und die
hypnose waren drei oder vier sitzungen
und ich muss sagen sie haben wie so ein
erstes pflaster gewirkt also ich habe
mich wirklich sofort besser gefühlt ich
musste allerdings monat auf einen termin
warten
weil das natürlich irgendwie nicht sehr
beliebt ist aber es gibt halt nicht so
viele hypnose therapeuten und wenn es
eine gibt die es dann halt ausgebucht
auch wenn sie sehr sehr teuer ist weil
man sich auch natürlich selber zahlen
muss die krankenkasse übernimmt das
glaube ich jetzt nicht wirklich und es
war wie ein erstes pflasters hat meine
symptome geschwächt ich hab so ein
bisschen mehr das gefühl gehabt mein
leben wieder im griff zu haben
aber ich hatte immer noch das gefühl
dass mein leben immer noch so 1 travel
ist und ich hatte immer noch das gefühl
dass wenn ich viele sachen schon
verstanden habe und irgendwie sich
beruhigt haben
es war aber noch nicht das was ich
wollte also dieses wirklich frei sein
und meine hypnosetherapie über super
also die hat auch viel vielen vielen
leuten geholfen das weiß ich und die
google rezensionen war mich am anfang so
begeistert bei die wirklich wie dieses
wie diesen schalter umlegen geklungen
haben und ist auch bestimmt für viele so
gewesen
für mich war es aber noch nicht das
optimale es haben sich aber glaube ich
auch andere sachen in der hypnose
therapie gelöst also es ging dann im
endeffekt nicht nur meine panikattacken
sondern sie hat ein ganz vielen anderen
baustellen gearbeitet wo ich heute sagen
muss ich glaube das hat echt also hätte
ich das nicht gemacht wird es mir
vielleicht auf anderen ebenen immer noch
schlechter gehen
es hat viele viele sachen ja irgendwie
aus der kindheit so so wie vergangene
traumata es muss endlich mal alles ein
großes trauma sein aber vergangene
traumata hat sich glaube ich schon echt
lösen können und da werde ich nicht
tiefer eingehen weil das ist auch ein
bisschen zu privat aber ja manche sachen
die man erlebt hat hat sie glaube ich
mir wieder gelöst und darüber bin ich
echt glücklich aber sie hat halt nicht
die panikattacken sie hat diese komische
angst vor dem tod konnte sie mir nicht
nehmen
diese irrationale angst dass mir
wirklich was passiert weil es bei mir
wird irgendwas passieren ich werde
irgendwann sterben das ist einfach
sicher und ob es jetzt mit 80 ist oder
nächste woche
der tod kommt für alle und man darf sich
da verhalten nicht so fürchten und wenn
man aber in diesem park attacken drin
ist oder in dieser diesem mindset dann
fürchtest du dich davon
das ist so wie wenn du jemandem sagt der
auf einem
von thom steht hat doch keine höhenangst
umfeld sucht sich runter da wird dir
genauso sagen ich weiß aber ich hab also
man kann dieses gefühl nicht abstellen
deswegen ist es ja so schlimm wenn man
es könnte dann würde ja keiner mehr
therapeuten oder irgendwas anderes
brauchen so und dann habe ich die
hypnose therapie gemacht und die war ja
schon ganz gut aber ich hab gemerkt dass
es immer noch nicht weg ist danach habe
ich die klassischen psychotherapie
begonnen bei einer auch sehr netten
psychotherapeutin und sie hat mit mir
erstmal aufgeschlossen wie so eine
panikattacke entsteht und das ist ja so
ein teufelskreis also man spürt ein
symptom darauf lenken seine
aufmerksamkeit dadurch entwickelt sich
die angst und es kommen mehr symptome
durch die angst dann spielt man wieder
dieses symptom was halt jetzt durch die
angst gekommen ist also herzrasen zum
beispiel oder atembeschwerden
das macht ihr wieder in der wahrnehmung
also du bewertest es dann und sagt okay
ich kriege es schlecht läuft bewertet es
uns macht ihr wieder angst und das ist
so toll so eine spirale ist so eine
spirale wo du dann reinfeldts wurde am
ende ja wirklich dich fühlst als optisch
gerade ein löwe angreift das ist auch so
das schönste beispiel ja für
panikattacken wenn du eine panikattacke
hast ist es eigentlich so aus der
evolution heraus super weil dein blut
wird schneller durch gepumpt du könntest
quasi fliehen laufen weg vor dem
tödlichen löwen da aber heutzutage
unsere feinde nicht mehr lösen sind
sondern halt social anxiety also soziale
begegnungen manche leute angst davor rot
zu werden manche leute angst vor
menschen zu sprechen
manche leute haben angst davor zu
sterben
und das ist dann halt so unser löwe und
mein löwe wahrheit diese angst davor
dass mir irgendwas passiert völlig
bescheuert aber ja dass ich ein
irgendeine krankheit habe dann habe ich
diese psychotherapie begonnen und konnte
damit schon besser arbeiten war aber
immer noch nicht alles so ganz also
meine meine körperlichen symptome haben
mich immer noch genervt
also habe ich mich von kopf bis fuß
durchchecken lassen
nicht bei einem normalen arzt also ich
bin nicht zu einem hausarzt gegangen
weil die jecken schon relativ schnell
was es mit ihr ist oder meinen zu wissen
was ist mit dir ist und wir wollen dich
dann nicht weiter behandeln oder
natürlich nicht also ich wurde nicht
weiter behandelt
so sehr ich mir gewünscht hätte
irgendwie überweisungen für irgendwelche
zu kriegen aber keiner hat mich ernst
genommen
also habe ich es privat aus eigener
tasche bezahlt deswegen monetarisieren
ich dieses video auch sicher ich möchte
den von ihm hören jetzt machst du mit
deiner krankheit geld ich habe so viel
geld ausgegeben für diese scheiße
und ja ich hole mir das geld zurück das
eigene tasche bezahlt diese untersuchung
ich habe komplett
ich hatte ein mrt in ganzkörper vom korb
von der wirbelsäule von ich habe ein
großes blutbild lang nicht langzeit ekg
aber leistungs ekg also wenn man so
strampeln muss ein belastungs-ekg so
heißt das belastungs-ekg ich habe
wirklich ist war steuer ich will hier
gar nicht erzählen wie viel es kostet
ich will kein auf diese idee bringen das
zu machen macht es nicht teuer und da
ist alles natürlich super bei
rausgekommen alles komplett aber ich
hab' ich habe wirklich wochen nur bei
ärzten verbracht ich wusste dass es mir
gut geht und ich wusste dass ich nichts
habe und trotzdem habe ich es geschafft
mir wieder so gedanken zu machen
da hat er nicht ganz auf dieses bild
geschaut vielleicht hat er ja doch einen
dunklen fleck oder so übersehen und ich
habe da vielleicht doch krebs oder ein
tumor im kopf oder irgendwas könnte ja
da immer noch sein
dann denkst du dir wieder so nein das
wird schon alles gut sein
also was für ein glück oder unglück
müsste man haben dass da jetzt was
übersehen wurde
ich mein das war ja deren job du hast es
ja aus eigener tasche bezahlt und sie
gucken ja schon darauf ob alles in
ordnung ist ja aber sie haben ja auch
viel zu tun also man macht sich so so
einen kopf um er heute würde ich sagen
schwachsinn aber noch nur weil es mir
wieder gut geht und dabei dachte ich so
jan man kann sie ja diese gedanken oder
sorgen machen sollte man nicht tun
ja und dann war alles okay
muss ich sagen
es war wirklich okay also ich habe mit
yoga angefangen kundalini yoga habe ich
zweimal die woche gemacht ich habe ja
hier meine wohnung ausgeräuchert ich
habe mit meditation begonnen
das waren alles so pflaster die meine
situation besser gemacht haben also ich
kann euch auch wenn ihr keine
panikattacken habt und euch nur manchmal
gestresst fühlt probiert euch an
meditation und an yoga
ich weiß es klingt wie so ein visco girl
trend weil alle plötzlich darüber
sprechen aber es gibt einen grund warum
alle darüber sprechen weil es einfach
hilft und jetzt verrate ich euch was
wirklich meine panikattacken aufgelöst
hat ein hörbuch was sie bei audible
gehört habe dass keine order bewerbung
ich mache es nur sagen dieses hörbuch
wurde mir unter meinem panikattacken
video empfohlen wochen später nachdem
ich dieses video hochgeladen habe und
dass ich dieses kommentar gesehen habe
war auch so ein zufall weil ich einfach
auf meiner kommentar seite war wohl ich
alle kommentare von allen videos sehen
kann und ich weiß gar nicht warum ich
auf dieser seite war ich habe auch
einfach nur durch gestreut und ich weiß
auch nicht warum ich dieses eine
kommentar überhaupt gesehen oder gelesen
habe auf jeden fall war das hier dieses
kommentar universum hat gesagt hey ich
hatte zehn jahre panikattacken und ich
habe wie untethered so gehört und meine
panikattacken bahn danach weg und ich
habe das so gelesen und dachte mir wow
krass das ist ein hörbuch schafft naja
ich hab ja eh noch guthaben bei orde
bild also hole ich mir jetzt einfach mal
und hörst mir an
ich habe nebenbei aufgeräumt weil ich
auch dachte auch das höre ich mir jetzt
nebenbei mal so ein bisschen an
ich musste ständig beim aufräumen pause
machen weil ich einfach nur da stand und
mir vor freude tränen liefen weil ich
das gefühl hatte dass dieser mensch zwar
auf englisch mir direkt ins herz
gesprochen hat und ich weiß nicht wie er
es geschafft hat
ich sage euch gleich so ein bisschen zum
inhalt des buches also was worüber er
spricht
aber schon nach dem dritten tag als ich
mit dem buch fertig war habe ich gemerkt
dass diese dunkle wolke über dem kopf
dass die weg ist und mir sind viele
dinge klar geworden dass diese
panikattacken nur die spitze des
eisberges waren das ist mir vorher auch
nicht gut ging aber dass ich besser klar
gekommen bin
diese panik attacken waren einfach nur
das signal meines körpers stop hör auf
nicht mehr so weitermachen wird war es
jetzt lass also stopp ich habe schon die
letzten jahre durch diese ganze magen
geschichte durch einfach wie mein kopf
eingestellt war
es gab gar keinen grund es ich war
einfach nicht mehr ich selbst und ich
war auch nicht mehr glücklich ich habe
nur von tag zu tag so alles hinbekommen
und erst seit vier wochen geht es mir
wieder richtig gut ich bin ich selbst
ich bin zufrieden
ich habe keine ängste ich gehe gerne aus
der haustür und wenn ich auch mal einen
schlechten tag habe und nicht aus der
haustür gehe dann mache ich mich nie
dafür fertig und fragt mich um mein gott
warum schaffe ich es nicht heute aus der
haustür zu gehen
ich denke mir einfach nur ja ja ja ist
das leben so warum werde ich vielleicht
wieder machen und wenn nicht dann nicht
aber vielleicht brauche ich mal diesen
tag an dem ich heute deprimiert bin
damit halt am nächsten tag wieder die
sonne scheint also was mir wirklich klar
geworden ist dass das leben kann nicht
immer on top of everything best of best
alles sein
das leben geht im leben geht es gerade
darum das ist einbrüche gibt dass du
weißt dass du alles verteufeln siehst du
denkst was mache ich bloß hier aber das
sind diese einzigen momente wo du dinge
verarbeitet und wo du wo du neue kraft
schöpft um weiterzumachen
man kann es kann einem nicht immer gut
gehen und selbst diese panikattacken
phase die ich
hatte die jetzt sechs monate gehen und
was noch sehr wenig ist weil ich es gibt
fälle
es gibt draußen fälle da haben leute
seit fünf jahren panikattacken aber
dennoch gut dabei aber selbst diese
letzten sechs monate in denen es mir so
furchtbar ging nehme ich dankend mit
meinem herzen an und sage danke danke
dass mir das passiert ist damit ich
daraus lernen kann damit dinge daraus
entstehen können die mich weiterbringen
und zum glück bin ich nicht mehr so wie
ich im januar war zum glück habe ich
panik attacken im 4 pro bekommen weil
ich will nicht so sein wie ich im januar
war ich will so sein wie ich jetzt genau
bin und das wäre niemals passiert wenn
ich diese panikattacken nicht bekommen
hätte und dann ist meine anlage sich
dafür zu bedanken für die schlimmste
zeit die man eigentlich im leben hatte
das hörbuch muss gut sein
fachleute in diesem hörbuch geht es
darum dass der autor michael singer dir
klar machen möchte wer du wirklich bist
und was du wirklich bist und es ist sehr
philosophisch psychologisch und ein
bisschen spirituell und es geht am
anfang im grundsatz darum dass du nicht
deine gedanken bist du bist auch nicht
deine meinung zu dingen du bist nicht
dein wenn du mir gutes machst dann bist
du mir guter menschengeschlechts macht
ist ein schlechter mensch darum geht es
gar nicht es geht darum dass du nur die
wahrnehmung von allem dem bist was da
draußen passiert du nimmst dein
trauriges gefühl genau so war wie den
apfel der am baum hängt es sind alles
nur objekte und es ist jetzt aus meinem
mund an dich ansatzweise so toll wie er
das geschrieben hat und so einleuchtend
dass du da sitzt und die tränen laufen
weil du erleichtert bist über diese
erkenntnisse aber so ist ungefähr der
inhalt dieser erkenntnis habe ich
wirklich dazu geführt dass ich alles was
passiert wenn ich mich aufrege vor allem
dann merke ich das ganz besonders ich
bin in dieser situation drin als ob ich
irgendwie da drin verschlungen wäre und
mich
irgendwann dann wieder rausholen kann
und sagen kann moment mal warum regt
mich das denn gerade so auf die hat mich
doch nur angebrüllt so das ist ja also
das berührt das darf mich ja nicht
länger berühren weil das ist ja nicht
mein problem dass hier zum schlechten
tag hat und mich angebrüllt hat ich
lasse mir doch jetzt nicht den tag davon
versagen und es klingt so easy oder so
zu einfach um wahr zu sein aber am ende
ist es dass ich halte mich aus allen
situationen wieder ein stück zurück oder
ich besinne mich in mein inneres in
meine wahrnehmung und weiß dass das
alles nur kleine erlebnisse sind im
leben auf und ab und alles passiert so
vor meinen augen und ich halte mich an
nichts so lange fest worum es noch in
diesem buch geht ist dass du deine
energien die in deinem körper fließen
und ich weiß das klingt jetzt ein
bisschen spirituell aber bleibt trotzdem
dran dass du die frei fließen lässt
und es geht darum sich nicht zu
verschließen sobald eine situation
unangenehm wird gerade finde ich ganz
passen bei meinen panikattacken
da hat man dieses gefühl nicht sie
aufkommen lassen wollen war wodurch man
sich so richtig verkrampft hat also ich
war wie erstarrt wie wie als ob ich
versuche auch so eine mauer für diesem
gefühl was jetzt kommen möchte zu
errichten und es bloß nicht durch zu
lassen und bloß mein herz zu
verschließen
das kind so mein herz zu verschließen
und das hat aber alles noch schlimmer
gemacht weil es hat sich angestaut und
angestaut und angestaut und angestaut
bis es irgendwann gebrochen ist und ich
wieder auf dem boden lag und nichts
konnte ich habe einfach in diesem ganzen
prozess von dem hörbuch gelernt mein
herz offen zu lassen und wenn dieses
gefühl kommt es voll und ganz zu lassen
denn dieses gefühl wird com und es wird
unangenehm sein
aber wenn man offen bleibt wird es ganz
schnell wieder verschwinden und das ist
so unglaublich hilfreich und ich merke
ich kann den inhalt dieses buches nicht
so gut erklären weil ich finde das ist
etwas was man erleben muss ich würde
euch auch ganz toll wenn ihr englisch
versteht gut versteht würde ich euch das
hörbuch empfehlen weil ich mag einfach
diese stimme und ich mag wie das
geschrieben ist es ist schön es als
hörbuch zu hören weil dann
man sich ganz tief entspannen und
einfach nur zuhören und muss nicht lesen
es gibt aber auch auf deutsch das
deutsche buch heißt deine seele will
frei sein also falls du an panikattacken
leidet an social anxiety an anderen
lebenskrisen dieses buch sollte eine
pflichtlektüre werden weil das irgendwie
die angst vom leben oder dieser stress
vom leben ich kann es nicht so ganz
beschreiben ich finde aber wirklich wenn
man irgendwie am struggle ist egal wie
ich würde dieses buch jedem empfehlen
es hat einfach sein leben verändert
scherz immer rum und sagt meine neue
bibel geworden so gut ich hab so viel
geld ausgegeben für psychotherapie
hypnose wird das für ärzte für brave
alles mögliche für akupunktur
es war auch alles schön und hätte noch
alles geholfen aber was mir am ende
geholfen hat war dieses blöde hörbuch
und es war wirklich ich bin so dankbar
dass ich einfach gehört habe und ich
hatte am anfang noch schwierigkeiten bzw
habe ich manchmal noch phasen wo ich
dann merke ich kann mich nicht so gut
entspannen und dann mache ich wieder das
hörbuch für paar minuten an
beziehungsweise das ist dann vielleicht
auch eine stunde durchlaufen und höre
mir nochmal so viele dinge vergisst man
natürlich auch ich habe es gehört und
habe da also immer wieder so aha momente
und so schöne erkenntnisse gehabt aber
natürlich in der nächsten woche weil sie
nicht denke ich jetzt nicht an jedes
wort was er da geschrieben hat sondern
musste es mir dann noch mal irgendwie
passagen anhören und waren nochmal so
ach ja stimmt und ich bin komplett
panikattacken frei und ich bin nicht nur
panikattacken frei im januar also oder
bevor ich die panikattacken hatte konnte
ich ja nicht wohin fahren ohne dass ich
sorgen hatte dass ich angst da dass ich
dachte hoffentlich geht alles gut
hoffentlich tut mir auch nicht unterwegs
wesentliche sich nicht irgendwie auf
toilette hoffentlich habe ich das und so
und ich bin ja jetzt auch vor paar
wochen nach new york geflogen das war
nicht möglich die letzten vier jahre war
das nicht möglich ich habe soeben gesagt
ich hätte 10.000 euro auf die hand
kriegen können ich hätte nicht europa
verlassen für 100000 hätte ich nicht
verlassen ich dachte ich krieg so etwas
nicht hin aus irgendwelchen gründen
und nachdem ich dieses buch gehört hab
dich so lust darauf ich hatte so lust
darauf man new york zu sehen und dann
als wir jetzt wieder nach hause gekommen
sind dachte ich so was was gucken kelly
und nicht ins nächste sun südkorea
südafrika und das ist so schön und ich
glaube gar nicht dass ich irgendwie
bisher den panikattacken nicht dachte
dass ich also ich dachte man dass ich
das nicht haben möchte ich dachte mal so
ach nee ich bin gar nicht so der
reisetyp ich bin schon zufrieden zu
hause nein ich war immer zufrieden damit
wenn alles nach mainz also wenn alles so
in meinen vier wänden die ich kenne und
aufgebaut habe passiert und alles was
ein bisschen mut und ein bisschen mehr
einsatz erfordert hat habe ich nicht
gemacht und ich habe es mir immer schön
erklärt mit na ja aber ich will sie auch
gar nicht und ich will den job da ja
auch gar nicht und ich will
nee das ist gar nicht mein ding es war
alles mein ding
reisen ist auch mein ding aber ich hatte
vor allem angst alles hat mir angst
gemacht und es war ein leben was
funktioniert hat denn besonders mit
meinem job wo ich ja in meiner wohnung
sitzen kann und niemals das haus
verlassen muss aber das funktioniert
also jetzt kann ich die ganzen reise
blogger verstehen die ich hier mal life
is for living machen
lebensecht von living und sterben werden
wir alle und so schlimm sei die hat auch
jeder keiner redet gerne mit anderen
menschen bzw mit fremden vielleicht
gibts da dort aber nicht viele
nur wenn du es nie machst dann führt
dass du immer deine angst und sagst ja
du hast recht
wir sollten jetzt echt nicht mit dieser
fremd person reden weil es könnte ja
sein dass wir uns blamieren und was
passiert bloß wenn wir uns blamieren und
damals in der schule da wurde es doch
auch immer hast du auch mal in der
öffentlichkeit gesprochen in dem referat
und dann würdest du dann hast du dich
blamiert weil irgendwie was passiert ist
das sind alles sachen mit mit diesen
lasten muss man nicht leben mit diesen
lasten also man kann komplett last frei
leben weil wir diese lasten nicht sind
denn nur die wahrnehmung und ich möchte
am liebsten dass ihr alle bitte jetzt
sofort euch das hörbuch holt und euch
dieses hörbuch anhört und glücklich sein
so glücklich wie ich weil ich glaube ich
war noch nie so glücklich in meinem
leben dass ich das mal sagen kann
panikattacken sind vorbei und ich
wünsche wirklich jedem da draußen der an
panikattacken leidet oder an anderen
sachen grades fahrgeld das glück das ich
jetzt führe und dass diese zufriedenheit
und dieses geschafft ich habe marathon
gelaufen ich bin marathon gelaufen und
es ist vorbei so ich hab das ziel
erreicht ich bin jetzt erleuchtet und
glücklich und frei atmen
ich habe euch das video gefallen ich
hoffe ihr habt nichts vergessen ich
wusste nicht was ja und sag mal so alles
hat ein ende nur die wurst hat zwei
bis dann euer disco girl vanessa ich
werde jetzt weiter an anderen videos
drehen und schneiden und
aber ja alle ganz doll lieb solcher
videos die machen ein irgendwie müde
ich glaube weil man sich so komplett
öffnen muss sein ganzes herz ausschüttet
mit dem wissen dass es über tausende von
leuten sehen werden
aber ich lass euch vom leben nicht
fertig machen und falls ihr klatschen
gehört habt das war mein stuhl der
übrigens von noble chances habe ich
geschenkt bekommen deine schön er ist
wunderbar mein rücken tut nicht mehr weh
das laut